hi there steve coffin here
today i want to talk about context the
importance of context in language
learning
context is a bit big part of our our
learning process in my opinion
because it's also so important to
whether we can understand something um
i'll give you
very quickly a few examples um when i
was in st petersburg about five six
years ago and i had been studying
russian
and i went to buy a ticket in the train
station
uh i of course waited in line and then i
arrived uh at the counter there and the
lady said something to me that i had not
anticipated
her saying i i didn't have the context
and so i couldn't understand what she
was saying even though i knew the words
i
just caught me by surprise
if i had been a regular you know
visitor to the train station buying
tickets i would understand everything
that she said
but i wasn't used to it i must say that
i did much better in la vie ukraine
maybe my ukrainian was better but also i
had a better sense of what the person
behind the counter
was saying
another example even in my own language
i was at uh whole foods which is store
as a store i never go to
uh to buy brown sugar cubes for my
coffee
and i didn't know that at whole foods
uh when you check out
at the cash register they ask you and if
you have your own bag like i bring my
own shopping bag
they ask you if you want 10 cents off
your purchase or whether you want to
contribute to a charity
and because
i didn't realize this i didn't have the
context
the girl at the cash register said you
want 10 cents off or you want to convert
your journey
i didn't understand what she was saying
and she had i asked her to repeat it
about two or three times
and then she explained the context that
they have the system she assumed that i
was a regular shopper when she explained
that to me then i understood what she
was saying so context is very important
to our comprehension
context is also important to
learning and i think you know recently
i've been talking about motivation i've
been talking about the importance of
repetition and novelty both i've been
talking about the importance of having
you know simple tasks that you can just
do without worrying about how you're
doing uh i tend to avoid any sort of
language learning tasks which involve me
trying to think or to remember or get
something right i just do these tasks
repetitively whether it be listening or
even you know and i'll get into this
doing some of our
flash cards and other activities as i
turn the page and link
but always i do stuff that relates to a
context
and that is why for example i found the
uh
the assimil book for arabic
which i was persuaded to buy when i was
in bratislava by a person who works for
the german assimil and he said this was
the best book and i in fact someone here
at youtube suggested the same
but what i found in there is that as
they introduce the language and
introduce a lot of explanation and stuff
it's always based on sort of one simple
you know sentence
the man went in the house the boy roped
the man sat down
which there's no context so i i find it
very tough
sledding as we say very hard to continue
in that book so i really have not spent
any time with the assimil book
whereas when i do our mini stories now
people are going to criticize me you
know slamming asimil promoting link i'm
sorry that's what i do i do what i think
works for me so the many stories that's
a context now it's not
totally
exciting content like stephen crash and
talks about compelling content
i still find that at the beginning stage
we kind of have to deal with
a context that is still a context
there's a little mini story there
it's meaningful to me because i'm trying
to understand it and i'm trying to
understand it when i hear it
so that it's a challenge for me to do
that so to that extent it is a context
and it's meaningful but it's not
something that is is tremendously
exciting it's not like reading about the
history say of uh i don't know
syria or something in arabic which
hopefully one day i'll be able to do
so context
is how i like to learn and i think it's
uh
i i don't worry
i don't worry about what i remember
don't remember
as long as i stay in the context
uh and i think our brains work that way
we need that context another example i
was driving this morning in the fog here
in vancouver and all of a sudden i
wasn't so certain about
where i should turn because normally
when there's no fog i see i get all
these hints from trees and buildings and
stuff so automatically i know where to
go when a lot of that sort of
surrounding context is taken away
then it's more difficult so i i think
the words that come together with other
words are very useful content context
for our comprehension and so i think
it's quite legitimate to do most of our
learning in some kind of a meaningful
context so for example in my arabic
learning
and i should say it's
why i'm talking so much about my arabic
learning is that you know in learning
other languages you know slavic
languages romance languages obviously i
have an advantage because i have learned
other slovak slavic or romance languages
but maybe
me learning arabic is like someone who
is learning a second language for the
first time where everything is new and
difficult and different so with arabic i
have a different writing system i have
you know essentially no very very few
vocabulary items that are common to
languages that i know
and so i'm finding it very useful to
stay in the context of our many stories
and to do what we call sentence view
which is what i do uh on the computer or
it's only on the browser version so i
can't do it on my app
but i look at it sentence by sentence i
i highlight the words that i need to
look up or to remember
and then i will highlight two or three
of them together to create a little
phrase and i'll often highlight the
whole sentence so that i can hear
the text to speech of the whole sentence
so i can hear the text to speech of the
individual word of a short phrase and of
the whole sentence and then as i turn
the page at link move to the next
sentence of course i have to do
these activities so again simple tasks
like i spoke about earlier simple tasks
that we just do so for me the flash
cards i just put all the flash card
stuff on the front page i don't on the
front page of the flashcard i don't
scratch my brain but i look at it
um
you know listen to the text to speech
um
sometimes i you know there's five
different activities i've got you can
change the settings you can change which
activities you do you can change what's
on the front page the back page of the
flash card there are a number of
settings so i vary it a variety again i
vary it and i go through the word the
phrase sometimes the sentence in these
activities but i am doing this review
activity closely related to the context
of the sentence and the sentence in turn
is tied to the context of the story so
everything is contextually linked it's
part of something bigger so i find that
more satisfying as a learning
activity
it helps me understand
and i recognize that perhaps i
understand the word in this context and
when i next run into the word i may have
forgotten it or it may have a different
meaning in a different context it
doesn't matter it's just this continuous
exposure to the language in a meaningful
context
with repetition and novelty
and simple tasks that repeat
and i i just feel myself becoming more
powerful in arabic certain you know i'm
over a hundred known words according to
my statistics
um there's probably more than that but
i'm a bit reluctant to move them there
just yet
um
some of the stuff that i saw
in my little arabic grammar that i have
leafed through a couple of times i'm
starting to pick up pick up on those you
know whether it's a
you know the verb whether it's a he or a
she or an i or a u and and some of the
endings of the nouns depending on
whether it's my book or something all
i'm starting to see or a book the book
i'm starting to see these things
but here again
our objective at link is to have grammar
notes for each of these sentences so
that the grammar note would be tied to
the specific context where it occurred
in the future we're also having planning
to make it possible to to basically have
the natural voice sound
attached to that sentence so those are
some of the things that we want to
introduce but in the meantime even as it
is i find it very useful it is sort of a
context based learning activity and i
am enjoying my arabic and i feel that
i'm making progress and i think
at least for me and i can't speak for
everyone at least for me learning in a
meaningful context is very important so
thank you for listening and i look
forward to your comments bye for now
[Music]
you